the nervous system is just wires and
cables even after death the muscles
responded to electricity being a bad
animator at give me the opportunity to
live action was great for me because it
got me as her out of my shell and I do
tend to learn how to talk to people for
the first time in my life so you know
the project that meant a lot to me sort
of based on a relation you know that I
had with a dog when I was a kid you know
that's a first kind of relationship
where it's very pure you know and and so
the idea of a boy and his dog and the
Frankenstein story just seemed like a
natural fit I like this kind of movie so
it was like it didn't seem like a weird
combination seemed quite natural you
know you should get that with humans
it's a very pure relationships kind of
simple elegance as the first you know
experience you had when I was a child
with death you know and so you know
memorable excel I'm you know the
opportunity doing it stop motion black
and white 3d you know made it it was
important for me to feel like it was a
new project strangely it's hard to put
into words but it makes it more
emotional and it you know people
complain about 3d and being dark and
murky but interesting with the black and
white it just it's still sharp it's it's
something really beautiful about it so
Jimmy just fits the story and it fits
the technique and it's like part of the
character of the piece and i don't know
why i think you get rid of the color you
focus more on simpler things emotions
and things and it just seemed
appropriate may I don't do the
stop-motion I left animation a long time
ago I because I was you know I didn't
have the patience I was very frustrated
animator and at the time the projects
that were that good you know so I got
quite disillusion but I do always you
know from watching ray harryhausen
movies I love stop motion and it is a
special type of person I do admire them
very much because they you know it's you
know sit in the dark removing a puppet
you know one frame at a time and it
takes a real special kind of artist to
do that so you know I it's probably my
favorite form of animation especially
with the right project I tried to make
everything as personal as possible in
terms of a memory or a type of person or
person that I recall like I said
teachers kind of environment and you
know kind of area that I grew up in
sober bank even down to this in the
architecture of Burbank so you know it
was all trying to to go back into and
find anything that was personal so it's
a two so we're like I guess the
difference is it explores a bit more
kind of kid politic classroom stuff
other weird kids teachers this is a bit
more that life and you know in the same
way that like in the universal when they
started doing things like Frankenstein
versus the wolfman or you know house of
Frankenstein or house of dracula abbott
costello meet frankenstein where they
threw in the bunch of monsters into one
movie so it kind of goes back to though
that kind of structure of those kind of
movies and as a wallpaper I mean all you
know the costumes little dinosaurs and
every I mean no I mean that that's the
beauty of it and that's the thing where
I mean I'm glad they did that because
you know there is something beautiful
about the tactile nature of it and you
know
I mean I've done stuff where it's been
with computers and that can be great
stuff but there's something about being
walking into a room and just seeing
little props and sing little things it
just it just excites you you know I've
been so lucky to meet people you know
like Vincent Price or Christopher Lee
you know people that have inspired you
you know for your whole life and so you
know I've always I've always felt very
grateful that had that opportunity
amazing artist you know just them and
you meet these people and it's
interesting because you meet people like
that that have affected you then you
meet them and they're really nice people
you know that that means a lot like I
remember like out of my whole years of
school I probably had one or two good
teachers and everybody else was crap you
know or didn't inspire it is nice to see
kids especially younger you know have a
cool art teacher you know I mean it's
like it mostly just like oh wow you know
i i'd love to make that you know i'd
like to come you know to the class so
you should be inspired and that there's
no reason not to you know I mean it just
shows how weird and bad system that I
grew up and was because I did we weren't
inspire we just like Oh got a class and
you see when you get a good one it means
everything
you